good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of mid-southwest district
council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley leader of
mid-suffolk district council and i'm
chairing this meeting today
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversation
while others are speaking
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
and finally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
so please could members make sure they
are logged in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you
will be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded
now i'm going to move to the agenda item
one apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from council brewster
thank you
item two is to receive declarations of
pecuniary
other registerable or non-registerable
interests by members are there any to
declare
no
thank you item three
mca slash 21
51 is to confirm the minutes held on the
6th of april 2022
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
can i have a proposal please cancel
richardson propose council of whitehead
second thank you
the governor not officer
if you would conduct the vote please
thank you members the vote has now
started
gemma take your vote
four thanks
counselor having him
counselor burn
i have you please thank you
thank you chair that is carried that's
unanimous
thank you very much
item four is to receive notifications
and petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received
item five any questions by councillors
none received
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint audit
and standards committees that no matter
refer chair
thank you item seven
is the forthcoming decisions list does
anybody have any comments
item eight
mca
2022-2
the response to the national grid
non-statutory consultation
on the east anglia green overhead line
project
and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member for planning to introduce this
report
councillor bern
thank you
um good morning
uh this is paper mca
stroke 22 so two
and it provides you with the proposed
response to the non-statutory
consultation
on the east anglia green overhead line
project
this is a big and complicated
proposal
that is worrying for a great many of our
residents
the proposed response shown
at appendix a covers a detailed list of
technical matters which i won't go
through at this stage
the main thing i would like to emphasize
is that we are proposing to object
our overriding preference is for a
coordinated offshore approach to
minimize onshore infrastructure
and the associated impacts on the
communities and environment
subsea cabling options are being
developed for the north of england and
scotland
so why not here
in the absence of greater clarity around
the options for strategic offshore
coordination of transmission
transmission reinforcement
and a subsea alternatives for this
project
i propose that we object to the proposed
development at this time
on that basis i moved the recommendation
in section three of your report and
would ask for a second thank you
councillor fleming
thank you i'm happy to second this
proposal
thank you very much
um i've invited all members to attend
to present their responses to this
consultation and you will be allowed to
speak once for three minutes and this
will be timed
there's councillors mellon warboys field
and welum you will all be allowed to
speak
uh written responses have also been
received from councillors pratt ebern
norris and more boys
and these will be taken into
consideration in the response that we
give to the national grid
so i'm going to invite you
each in turn to speak uh council miller
thank you chair um
so i'd first like to make a couple of
overarching points about the council's
draft response before looking at the
details
um
firstly the proposed route for the
overhead cables shown on as a graduated
swathe on national grid maps
by my reckoning directly crosses eight
or maybe nine council wards from
palgrave and gizlingam in the north
down through back to the mendelssohn
still upland
touching the stoneham's ward then neda
market battsford and ringshaw blakenham
and finally brumford
of these wards i just make the point
that most are represented by councillors
in the opposition green and liberal
democrat group i make it something like
eight opposition councillors awards
affected compared to three
administration councillors
that being said
i welcome the opportunity that all
affected councillors have been given to
state their concerns to this cabinet
meeting and hopefully have some
influence on the council's response
and secondly as myself and councilman
morley have already discussed this is an
issue where i think there is likely to
be a strong cross-party consensus which
means that the council can speak
powerfully with one voice there may be
some slight differences in approach but
i think we are generally all on the same
page
since i only have three minutes i'll
leave my colleagues to make some more
detailed points however our main
concerns about this consultation are as
follows the firstly the timing of this
consultation seems to be inappropriate
i.e too soon since the government is
expecting this month the report of the
offshore transmission review group set
up by the department of business energy
and industrial strategy
whilst we welcome the increase in
renewable energy production there is a
lack of strategic long-term planning to
connect multiple offshore wind farms
into the national grid in a coordinated
way
thirdly the proposed overhead lines and
pylons will have a massive impact on the
area through which they pass
visually dominating the landscape and
also impacting heavily on many heritage
assets along the route
the overground route is only the best
value option for national grid if no
intrinsic value is ascribed to these
landscapes
and then fourthly there's a whole huge
issue of blight affecting properties on
or close to the proposed route and given
that this is only the first stage in a
very long process this could go on for
many years
i largely agree with the council's draft
response but i'd like to encourage a few
amendments
the response on page two highlights
underground in the whole route as
something that requires further
consideration i think this would be
vastly more expensive and more
environmentally destructive than an
undersea cable route and therefore seems
an unrealistic option
secondly some individual bullet points
if taken out of context appear to show
support for the scheme and should be
removed or edited
and lastly the benefits to the
communities through which the line may
pass on page 8
some potential benefits to discuss but i
think we should be demanding more of
national grid thank you chair
thank you councilman
council of war boys
a few comments i'll probably repeat what
has been
proposed by council burns
and uh
my colleague uh councilman first a
consultation
the response performer does much to
establish the need for and leaders to
support this proposal as the uk adopts
widespread use of renewable energy
so far so good but this is the only
green element of this proposal and the
only significant consultative part
it assumes that we have decided on the
car model and now for the options list
there are no viable alternatives
proposed
this consultation is about refining the
proposal
the proposal about the transmission of
power through suffolk it is not
driven by suffolk energy needs the
question needs to be asked why through
when it can go round
national grid has another project
ceiling which connects sizable rich
bring kent an offshore link
national grid identified 23 possible
reinforcement solutions
and has produced a corridor and
preliminary routine and citing study
report
e7 the proposed scheme is not the
cheapest
the closest to e7 but with an offshore
link between norwich and grain is east
nine
a difference of 857 million
an easy decision what should expect
however these costs do not factor in the
individual cost to every householder
within 300 meters of the route
a study by dr sally sims
a lecturer at oxford brooks university
reveals that valuers and agents tend to
estimate the effect that overage of all
high voltage lines have on property
values
usually between two and twelve percent
their findings confirm that living close
to overhead power lines and particularly
pylons has a negative effect on the
resale value of homes
as much as 38 percent
homes within 300 meters of an overhead
power line sell for as much as a third
less than similar properties
in addition there is a socio-economic
effect of planning blight whilst
construction is underway
an offshore route would not be without
its environmental impact but in its own
assessment national grid claims to be it
is possible to mitigate this
gizmo ward is one small section
about 10 percent of the proposed route
the route passes wickham ski skirts
gizzard proceeds across the southern end
of mali's common passing three historic
monument sites in burger through wertham
and touching the edge of wertham ling a
triple s i before crossing the waveney
valley to bressingham
were them alone as 58 great two
buildings
this part of suffolk retains its
medieval settlement patterns interferes
with commons
ancient woodlands and rolling farmland
it is an important asset as an amenity
to local residents and also an important
aspect of what makes suffolk attractive
to tourists
this cannot be valued easily but to
dismiss it as collateral damage is
short-sighted to say the least
thank you councillor voice the
overarching national policy statement
for energy em5 sets out the factors
influencing sight and roots
sorry am i going on okay
you've been stopped oh i can't hear you
i'm sorry al
can i just sum up
you may finish your sentence last
sentence
i asked smith suffer
district council because
rejecting tote with his proposal to
appeal directly to off gem and the
secretary of state that the offshore
route 9 be reappraised in the light of
the excessive costs of the overland
route in terms of financial impact harm
to our shared heritage and loss of
immunity to our residents these factors
should be considered in addition to the
basic structure thank you council boys
thank you councillor field
thank you
i hope my words are somewhat shorter but
there's always a risk
to put a local spin on it the local the
small rural village of floton is within
my broken on ward
it suffers
the presence of an existing 400 kv grid
connection for knowledge towards
twinstedt
a single pile online
which has been in place since the group
connection point of bullen lane 1.7
kilometers east of the village was
constructed
it has also tolerated the twin line that
connects size well to the grid and grid
connections other assets have multiplied
recently
the branford substation and woodland
lane will house here house the ea1 and
the a3 conversion and connection points
the village recognises that these assets
are of benefit to the country at large
but there's a limit to its tolerance and
east anglia green exceeds that tolerance
the proposed route affects many
communities but in floating it runs
between the church which is on the
southern side of the village and gate
farm
through a gap of only 500 metres
it goes over valley farm
so barn and float and hall towards the
substation so it has a substantial
impact on the core of the village
this really is a step too far
should we expect floating community to
live with another major degradation to
their environment
i believe not
is there any alternative
in fact three
to improve building insulation provide
local power generation storage
to place the 400 kv lines underground
or to route the power directly from the
port
point of generation down the north sea
to the capital
we are told the last two options have
been considered but rejected largely on
ground of costs
underlying ground lines we're told are
three to ten times the cost of
parliament lines
perhaps three times in rural areas and
ten times in a city
we don't know but the option should be
explored in detail and estimates made
public
the technology is not revolutionary but
well known and deployed in areas such as
aombs
the impact on electricity bills across
the country of this necessary good
reinforcement should be identified and
be a penalty on whom
will bennett
will benefit
it should not be hidden behind
insurances and national grid have
examined the possibilities and find them
too costly
the more attractive option would be to
route the connections directly from
north sea assets using d-segment c
technology to the area of need
the converter stations to achieve this
are required wherever the power is
landed so the increased cost is limited
to that
additional cable length
the technology involved is known and
cable loading process in under sea does
not involve trenching and duct work
burial on land requires
we informed that the power capacity
required would involve multiple tables
which is true but this directly
comparable to the combined capacity of
five existing links
the 270 kilometer norwegian link
suggests that the length of connection
required would not be a problem
grid statements on the cost of that link
at four million working hours perhaps
indicate what could be expected
counselor field final sentence please
okay um
the only estimate of the cost of the
grid i could find was point two pence
per kilowatt hour delivered that's the
cost of connections
if we multiply the entire cost by four
duplicating the entire grid at the lower
of the underground cost estimates it
would add 0.8 of a penny to the 32 pence
i'm currently paying
a two and a half percent
increase which is not welcome but
tolerable
to limit the damage to suffer
in conclusion i certainly support the
proposal that the district advocates and
undersea councillor fields thank you
thank you
councillor willem
three minutes
i've timed it's okay don't worry you
won't you have to remind me
before speaking about the proposed route
as it may affect mid-suffolk and in
particular the award served by
councillor e burner myself i'd like to
ask members if they would consider the
most logical and least damaging method
of transmitting energy from the north
sea to tilbury in the thames estuary
why would you first connect offshore
wind farms to norwich and then erect
miles of 50 meter high pylons through
south norfolk suffolk and essex
before any transmission lines are
implemented over land or underground a
national energy strategy is essential
suffolk mps should join with mps in
other parts of the country which might
be threatened by similar schemes to
ensure a uk-wide strategy is approved
before this proposal is considered
residents have told me they are confused
by the approach of showing a band of
interest rather than a specified route
most of those who have homes or own land
from which the pylons would be visible
or against an overhead scheme
others who fear the disruption of an
underground scheme object to such a
scheme and some believe they should
support the overhead scheme as the least
worst option
but the underground scheme would be
greatly disruptive during construction
and render unpredicted unproductive a
great swathe of land for many years
clearly the consultation is flawed as
there is no comparison of costs between
overland underground and undersea
options nor is there any comparison of
disk benefits of the three options for
instance effect on listed buildings
wildlife habitat visual immunity
agricultural production disruption
during construction and the
administrative costs of dealing with
potentially thousands of individuals
the economic cost due to loss of tourism
and other knock-on effects all the way
against the current proposal
through our award if the proposal goes
ahead 50 meter columns will stride
across the high clay plateau
and will be seen for miles around
listed buildings are within the colored
band
the effect on sss eyes wooded areas and
in particular gibbon great wood and the
whole range of conservation biodiversity
product projects is given no
consideration
some of the comments of national grid
staff have been unhelpful and in many
cases questionable we don't take matters
into account at this stage i was told
the technology for an undersea option
doesn't really exist
when questioned further i was told that
expert expertise does exist in the
private sector but surely now is the
time to come together to devise a
strategy for the uk
in discussion with one of the staff at
the need to market consultation he and i
agreed that the undersea option over the
life of the scheme would add only a few
pence per year to the average household
electricity bill and that's before
taking into account the savings from
using renewable sources of energy rather
than fossil fuels
members of cabinet you have an
opportunity today
to tell government that this proposal
and other similar schemes are
unacceptable and using your contacts
within government to urge an end to this
piecemeal approach and produce a
national energy strategy
fit for the future thank you
spot on counselor welum thank you very
much
so i've received written responses also
from councillors pratt ebern
norris
and warboys and all of those will be
taken into consideration in the response
that we give to national grid and they
will also be added to our online papers
so they're available for public viewing
do i have any questions from
cabinet you have any questions from
other members
councillor stringer um i didn't realize
i've missed the opportunity to be able
to speak on behalf of my residents
the
monitoring op team did
send out an email inviting
people to notify them should they wish
to speak
uh i do not believe we received such a
thing i had a question answered in here
that i would be given the opportunity to
speak if i turned up i didn't realize
how to put it in writing that i wish to
attend
thank you council stringer we sent out
an email we asked members to register
with us so that we could monitor how
many speakers we were going to have for
this meeting
um so there was an emails uh
then my mistake
i'm happy to make an exception and allow
you to speak for for three minutes thank
you
thank you
uh on behalf of the residents of uh of
menderson we're already having
uh significant
issues with the existing pylons
the amount of cabling on them is at this
moment being quadrupled
so the visual impact of the existing run
is already being impacted on the
presence of minstrel can we ask if we're
looking at the wording that we already
have in our submission are we able to
introduce the word strongly in front of
the word object
because i can i
i believe that most of my residents and
i believe the feeling of this council is
that we strongly object to this so if we
could cancel this this is your chance to
have three minutes to speak yes
not to ask questions at this point it
was a okay
the
right i have to rework what i'm going to
say okay
this
proposed broad uh rough route
in my community
it seems incredibly ill thought through
it goes through existing ancient
woodland
against the the own advice of national
grid it also goes through community
woodlands
which would render them then almost
useless
the i'd also like to see whether we
could uh
be a bit stronger about undergrounding
undergrounding is is a very uh nuclear
option in terms of the impact on the
land itself uh
it it does actually just sacrifice the
environment for aesthetics for decades
afterwards because you basically destroy
all sorts of rhizome networks etc etc
and the land will take decades to heal
if we do go underground so i'd basically
rule that out if i could
i think we also need to be a bit
stronger about land values
land values here along the section of my
ward i've calculated would have over
four million pounds worth of impact
on property values
now
that may be easily mitigated or lost in
the mix but many of those properties use
that value to fund business borrowing
so if that value is taken straight away
off their value they will be in a
negative equity situation with the
borrowers and banks for their own
businesses so actually this will have a
massive economic impact on on my area
and mendelssohn
wider so i don't think we should easily
dismiss the land value thing because it
will have a further
further
impact also in terms of the consultation
this doesn't feel i have to say like a
consultation it seems like we have the
opportunity to fine-tune a decision
already made
for me a consultation would have a range
of of options with the associated costs
and i think if we could uh ask for those
to be fleshed out more i think that
would that would be hugely hugely
beneficial so thank you for your the
ability to put some of the points from
mendelssohn ward
and like i say we from here know don't
just object we strongly object thank you
chair
thank you councillor
do cabinet have any questions
to other members
councillor fleming
question
um
thank you um
thank you councillor molly i would just
like to make sure i have some comments
that i would like to make publicly on
our proposed response and i'm not sure
whether i should make them now or later
when you open this up is it a question
it's not a question
then we'll save that for debate thank
you
does anybody cancel a field
thank you the question really is um
none of us are particularly expert in
this this area of endeavor i wondered
whether suffolk is considering anyway
employing an expert who will be capable
evaluating the proposals
and providing an assessment of estimates
to ensure that we
you
get
a
understandable and reasoned response and
some assurance that we have some
independent
evaluation
i'm not sure i've got anybody here who
can actually answer that question at the
moment cancer field but it's something
that we we can follow up on afterwards i
think
if i might advocate for a moment there
are such people who have that sort of
depth of knowledge who could provide
much better guidance than we can from
our individual counsellor positions
and just be just before we go into
debate i would like to make an amendment
to the recommendations
the recommendation is that the assistant
director for planning and building
control in collaboration
with the cabinet member for planning and
i would like to add myself as leader on
that because
we will be delivering a
a letter together with the response and
that letter will be in my name and so i
need to be part of that discussion
are you happy to accept that council
then
council whitehead
okay thank you very much
so who wants to start us off on the
debate
councillor fleming
yes thank you thank you very much and
um you know a lot of work has gone into
this
um
in on behalf of the officers and all
members i think we've all made a huge
effort to try to get to grips and
understand what's going on as have local
residents and i just like to say
publicly to local residents thank you
too because your input into this has
been really enormous and i'm going to
parish council meetings
um listening to what everyone has to say
there is an enormous concern out there
for what's at stake and and i do thank
everyone for their interest in in this
project and the strategic view that
local residents are taking it's this
isn't about nimbyism it's it's about a
major national decision
i just want to make a couple of comments
on the proposed response itself
and
just looking at
the
principle
which i think
i absolutely support our objection
and i'm not sure that tempering the
objections by saying it's strong very
strong or what i think an objection is
an objection is probably strongest
standing on its own
um
but also
um
i would like
the um
us to bring out in this letter the fact
that
there's been no public consultation
on the fundamental decision as to
whether to
onshore or offshore
and on the particular routes given
that it were to be unsure i haven't seen
a public consultation about that maybe
i've missed it but i think
as has been said this almost seems like
a done deal
and i feel that there should be
much more public openness about the
fundamental decision
and the cost-benefit analysis
and the financial background that has
led national grid
to prefer
an onshore system because we simply
don't have that information in the
public domain and i feel that our letter
should ask for it in very strong terms
there is um also the the financial
analysis as also has been pointed out
that we we do have seems to be fairly
superficial and doesn't seem to take
into account things like devaluation of
property values
devaluation of the landscape
for various reasons but particularly for
tourism and the tourist economy
i've seen no quantitative
financial
harm
out there for us to to assess these
things so the entire financial
background to the decision i feel is
lacking and that we must ask for it
and i will be saying the same to the
county council
on um
undergrounding i thought we might throw
in
an example of the waiver new valley
which has been discussed
because
it is a particularly sensitive area i
feel we should also throw in any
discussions we've had with our
colleagues in norfolk
which i know we have had
maybe baber will do the same with essex
i don't know but it's very important
that we show that we're talking to
our
neighboring local authorities
on the um key technical issues
we've got
a paragraph first off on aonbs and
there's only one aonb in baber and mid
suffolk and it's not in mid suffolk
i would like to see
landscape and visual impacts
as a paragraph following the discussion
on aonbs because it is really
the key issue here is landscape and
visual impacts and i'd like to see the
words visual impacts added to the
landscape subject title
um
because there are a lot of
visual impacts at stake
also i would like us to see more
discussion under the topic of landscape
and visual impacts on tower types
during the consultation national grid
was very reluctant to show us
the options for the different types of
tau
and
it may well matter if we are
despite our best efforts forced to
accept this onshore project
do we really have
a proper idea of the benefits of having
35
meter high
t-type pylons as opposed to 50 meter
high
you know the classical pylon types that
that's quite a big difference and it was
not brought out fully in the
consultation i think we need to
talk about it more in our response
also we don't talk about the effects of
this on
small private aircraft
there are a number of small airfields in
mid-suffolk i'm sorry i'm probably going
on beyond my time but
i know of one that may almost certainly
has been overlooked in wortham
and um i'm not sure they even know you
know properly that this is going on i
hope so but there is a real issue here
with small aircraft that i that isn't
discussed
um
and
just to in conclude
i i feel that our letter should provide
maybe half a dozen bullet points at the
end where our main
um the key points of what we're trying
to convey are written down so that
anyone picking this up can in five
minutes understand what we're trying to
say
so so that's
thank you very much for letting me speak
thank you cancer fleming now this is an
important subject and it deserves a full
airing
does anybody else wish to contribute
councillor gault
thanks thanks so much chair
um
think that clearly is a high degree of
uh consensus uh
uh on on this matter and that that's no
surprise
uh i would
say that um
certainly in terms of my contact with
parishes in my ward and beyond
that the concern is
is actually quite wide
in our county let alone uh in our
district and it's not just those that
are under well within the corridor
that are affected by this
a great many people enjoy
our landscape
and are very concerned about about this
issue um and i well i'm on that while
i'm
reading the the covering report i see in
our risk assessment we put something a
highly unlikely thing that we will fail
to consult or fail to demonstrate
community leadership i think this is a a
wonderful opportunity
for this council
to demonstrate community leadership in
the strength of the response
that it makes
to what
is called a consultation
but um
for those of you
uh only enough to remember lord denny
master of the rock once master of the
realms uh he i've been trying to find
this i can't find it he laid down a very
uh good definition of what constituted
consultation
and i don't think this uh would meet the
denning test
um i did hear
uh on
on the radio a representative of uh
national grid being interviewed
on this
and
reasonable points were being put to him
about the consideration of options uh he
said well actually our hands are tied on
this because the government
i'm paraphrasing but not much by much uh
the government has uh
obliged us to seek the the cheapest
solution to this
now
i think cheapest and easiest maybe for
national grid
i would hope that government would take
a slightly wider view of
what constitutes cost here and i'm not
certainly not going to
repeat
all the points have been made about
you know clearly we ought to object to
this uh in order to do it in the
strongest
possible terms
i'm not going to
repeat or go over the alternatives i
think we know what we are and i think
there is a consensus
consensus about the way
this should go
but actually
and and the point that that is being
made i think by
um council william and then
um
in your own amendment
chair to the
to the covering report about adding
yourself and a letter going in your name
uh
expressing the council's opposition to
this proposal is is very very important
indeed because
actually
what may appear to be cheap in the in
the short term
uh i don't think really is cheap at all
and certainly isn't going to be once you
start to calculate uh all the impacts
that the
proposed solutions
would have
so i think we need to make a very strong
objection to this
i think
the point about taking this to to
government and how our government and
how it views these issues is
tremendously important so i hope that we
will harness our objection to the uh
objections being raised by
our mps
in in suffolk
to get the greatest
political impact
that we can thank you very much
thank you councillor gold
uh thank you very much i i don't suppose
to go over any of the ground that's
already been gone over we've we've heard
some very useful uh comments and
observations
this morning
um
i'm very pleased to see that we've got a
pretty good consensus across the board
across the political board
of this council and i am concerned that
as many of our communities are
represented in in the response that we
we ultimately give
i'm going to have
a bit of work to do after this
transcribing from the
recording
jessica's uh
comments and um
peter's comments to
um
and andrews
but i can ask
randy and keith and roland and john if
um they wouldn't mind sending me
their written versions so that i've got
them in front of me when susie and them
i'm sorry i'm being very familiar we
shouldn't be
a little more
um
but
we're all we're all friends here so
when when we go through this and
consolidate those responses and pop them
into the into the
into the final consultation response it
would help me enormously if you could do
that so thank you very much
councilwhitehead
now
i'm struggling to remember
any time when i sat in this chamber and
agreed with everything that everybody
said but this isn't this is an occasion
i can't think i can't disagree with
anything that everybody said i'm no
expert on this and i think my only hope
is this is not a serious um proposal by
national group but just to try on
i certainly agree with the
comment council feel made about him
employing an expert i think that's
really vital
when my award was going to be affected
with the east anglia one to four i was
pleased to see that um it was all
undergrounded from bourgeois to branford
and there was a lot of destruction at
the time but now walking across the
footpath where those cables went it
really is impossible to see um
any effect and
my understanding is and those
undergrounding was taken under rivers
and
trunk roads and all sorts and it was
obviously expensive but
now it's done air and gone
and they're hidden and
so that clearly underground is better
than overground and but taking it down
the
north sea to me seems most sensible
and when i read these big proposals for
ginormous solar farms in morocco and
cables from morocco to the uk that go
into the bay of biscay and the atlantic
ocean then surely anything's possible so
i just think we should object it in the
strongest terms possible it's my view
thank you
does anybody else wish to contribute
thank you it's not really a second bite
i just
wanted given the
cancer-filled proposal seems to have
been seconded by council whitehead
whether we
we've got the
ability at this meeting
uh to make a decision uh to do that to
appoint an expert to support the
council's opposition
i'm going to look to tom but i'm
conscious that he may not have heard the
comment when it was made in real time
because he joined us later so i think
the proposal that i heard from cancer
field was that if we need to that we
appoint an additional expert or an
expert externally who can support us in
challenging the proposals conscious that
it's a highly complex uh consultation
i'll use the word loosely but highly
complex consultation that we would need
to look to so tom does that sound like a
reasonable
approach obviously separately we'll look
at how we fund it
he nodded
okay thank you
um
so if nobody else wishes to contribute
um
so the recommendation is that the
assistant director for planning and
building control
in collaboration with the leader and the
cabinet member for planning
consider any proposed amendments to the
suggested response
and be authorized to make amendments
before submitting a response to the
government
so i'm now going to ask the government's
officer to conduct that vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app and it is an
amended recommendation
chair
four thank you
counselor
chair that's eight votes for so that's
unanimous
excellent thank you very much thank you
everybody
moving on to item
nine is nca
22-3 the cost of living report an action
plan
and i now invite the cabinet member of
health and well-being to introduce his
report thank you
lovely thank you very much chair um if i
may i'd like to start by thanking the
officers present uh for producing this
paper particularly to nadim our
assistant director for communities and
wellbeing um as this will in fact be his
last meeting with us um so thank you
nadine for all of your hard work over
the last few months and i wish you all
the very best in the future
um in in introducing this report and the
associated action plan i want to
recognize at once
the importance of this issue
i know that residents and their families
across our district
have faced significant challenges in
recent months from rising gas rising
prices in gas electricity fuel and food
and will likely continue to do so for
the remainder of this year with
inflation due to peak at ten percent in
quarter four
we shouldn't underestimate the
significance of this for some people
this will be the highest rate of
inflation in their lifetime
myself included
but we also know that since the plans
this plan was published the chancellor
has announced a package of measures
worth 15 billion to help tackle the cost
of living crisis but i strongly believe
that the measures contained within this
report are still valid and indeed
valuable
there are a number of ways we already
support those on lower incomes from
tenancy and benefits advice through to
our council tax reduction scheme but we
can go further still
the action plan the appendix sets out
both what we do currently and what steps
we plan to take to help our residents i
don't plan to list them all individually
but they include a new cost of living a
coordinator to work with our partners
across the district the expansion of our
social prescribing scheme and the local
welfare assistance scheme that was set
up by suffolk public sector leaders
what i hope this report also makes clear
is that we will continue to utilize
mid-suffolk's particular strengths to
ensure that the support we offer is
data-driven and targeted to those most
in need that we work in collaboration
with our partners across the suffolk
system and as much as possible we aim to
prevent those who have fallen on hard
times from suffering a deterioration in
their broader health and well-being
in closing i would just like to reflect
on the purpose of it or the wider
purpose of this paper and what it is
asking us to do
as i mentioned the government has
already announced a large packet of
measures to help with this particular
issue and so what we're effectively
deciding today in my opinion is whether
our role as a district council is simply
to be a passive distributor of
government monies or whether we believe
it is our place to be proactive and
practical in the support we provide to
our residents
i firmly believe this should be the
latter and it goes almost exactly to
what council gould said earlier that
actually i want us to utilize this
opportunity to be playing that
leadership role in our communities and i
hope this action plan does just that
i'm very happy to therefore propose the
recommendations in this report and to
endorse this action plan to cabinet and
we'll ask for a second thank you chair
thank you councillor richardson
councilman i'm very happy to second the
report
chair thank you
do we have any questions from members
thank you chair yeah um i welcome the
plan as well
but i'm wondering how much of it is
already being done
and what a completely new initiative so
my questions are as follows um
when i don't need extra staff
um what is the cost to me suffolk of
implementing this plan um when will the
cost of living coordinator take up their
post
uh it says in summer that summer could
be june july or august um
and i
can't imagine it will be june but i hope
it's july um
obviously it could be an existing member
of staff
who's put into that post
and there are any other new members of
staff or any changes within
um within the organization
needed
um
in terms of the cost i guess it breaks
down to staffing projects and payments
to others so
i'm not expecting answers to all of
these today but if i could have those at
some point
um
but how will outputs be
be measured we've got the a list of
inputs here um we need to know uh
what what our outputs are you know our
kpis i guess almost but what outputs
we're aiming for and how they will be
measured so we know that we are actually
being successful with this plan in
alleviating the cost of living crisis
and my last point and i
always ask this sort of question because
i represent a rural area
how will residents in rural areas
without their own private transport be
able to access for instance gyms
swimming pools
healthy eating you know all the
initiatives that are listed in there
if you can't get out of your house
how are you going to
[Music]
be helped by this five-point plan thank
you
council richardson
thank you very much i'll try and answer
that as best i can but um i might invite
officers to come in if there are any
particular points um looking i think if
i just take them um as i've sort of made
a note of them in terms of the overall
cost i think you're quite right uh
councilwoman effectively what this does
is bring together in a really coherent
or hopefully in a really coherent
cohesive way a mixture of things we've
either already committed to or that of
work is work is going on with the
poverty board with suffolk county
council or some new initiatives so what
it does is just bring that together in a
really sort of integrated way to make
sure that we're looking at this in the
round um so the details on the cost will
be a mixture of um
expense that we've currently agreed
versus some additional that we're um
responsible for distributing um in terms
of cost of living facilitator i think
you've sort of almost answered that
question um in in in part of what you
said in so far as that obviously depend
on who the exact candidate is what their
existing notice period was whether they
were internal or external candidates so
that i think is something we wouldn't
have the detail on at the moment ditto
new members of staff i think that's a
bit tricky to answer because
specifically because some of this stuff
is work that's already ongoing we have
expanded the communities and well-being
team quite recently four new roles to
assist in exactly the delivery of this
type of work so it's sort of a slightly
blended approach
um in terms of outputs and measurements
um i think for the most part
this is where it gets a little bit
complicated so some of it will be in the
delivery plan that we have for the
well-being strategy and for the
community strategy for example
others bits of data so around the um
holiday activity and food program that
data sits with the county council so it
isn't easy to measure all of that um in
in sort of one coherent way um i think
that answers most things but if officers
would like to jump in um at any point
then happy to to
defer to them thank you chair
nadine vicky do you want to come in
i'm hoping you can hear me oh yeah you
can't sorry yeah i i think castle
richardson
answered um most of those points i mean
i i just
would add another once we have appointed
the
um
hustle living coordinator and systems
are further embedded we'll then
understand the intelligence better in
terms of some of that partnership
working particularly in relation to the
impact that that post is going to make
thank you very much
counselor welcome do you want to come
back home yeah chair the question about
how will people live your residence hope
housebound residents in rural areas
benefit from this five-point plan
because they they don't have their own
access
to public to private transport or public
transport so that that is a key issue
for for my ward
thank you thank jeff
jeff i mean apologies i missed off that
question um so i think that's part of
where this targeted approach comes in so
we know that with individuals with
particular health needs or particular
mobility issues we can work as part of
our integrated neighborhood teams with
our partners in health and social care
to make sure that we get bespoke um
solutions to individuals based on their
their individual circumstances and their
need
cancer stringer thank you chair uh
really good to have a plan and good to
see that we've now got one just one uh
observation
i make
given this council put back into
reserves almost the entire budget the
county used for lifting people out of
fuel poverty
should there not have been an energy
conservation element to this plan
given we have the expertise in-house
vis-a-vis building control etc etc so
i'm just wondering
good to have a plan but should we have
perhaps included a slice that included
lifting people out of fuel poverty and
energy conservation
thank you chair uh yes very good point
cancer stringer i think one of the sort
of key parts of this i won't be able to
find it sort of doing it live but is a
commitment that we continually review
this action plan so if there are further
down the line other elements that we
think will be particularly um valuable
and those can be included particularly
around um energy usage and energy
efficiency obviously i imagine that
would become
a greater importance as we move towards
the end of the year and as we approach
winter so i'm sure that's something we
could happily look at over the next
coming months
thank you
so does anybody wish to debate this item
councillors cabinet
councillor
i'd just like to add that we have a lot
of community activity going on and with
our locate location offices that will be
taking a locality each they will be
liaising with parish councils with
groups to find out exactly where that
need is
and
also um with our um our leisure
providers in stone market and stratfor
they will be looking to deliver some
some um activities in villages and
at home sometimes so you know it is all
going on but it is
just
you know
that um finding where the need is but um
and i think you know people are very
much together at the moment so if
someone needed a lift to a village hall
i think that community spirit is there
and hopefully we will see a lot more of
that community spirit going forward and
our locality officers can pick up on
that thank you chair
thank you councillor flatman thank you
councillor richardson
um
so i'd just like to add my thanks
to
nadim and thank him for all the work
that he's done on this together with his
team
with vikki and the rest of the team so
we're sorry to really sorry to be losing
you dean
your stay with us has been short and
powerful thank you
so i'm
the recommendations are to agree the
five-point plan attached at appendix one
and to delegate to the assistant
director for communities and well-being
in consultation with the cabinet member
for well-being to keep this plan under
review
and
also to update it in response to
emerging need
so i'm going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
chair may i have your vote please
thank you
chair that is uh eight votes for that's
unanimous
thank you very much
item 10 mca
22-4 is the stone market lca overview
and scrutiny committee recommendations
and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member for housing
and also communities to introduce the
report thank you
thank you i'll go first if the council
of that one doesn't mind each year
mid-suffolk council and citizens advice
help people to find a way forward with
housing advice money and advice and by
supporting them to navigate their way
through systems to overcome different
problems
mid-suffolk council and citizens advice
understand that people need different
types of support at various times in
their life and believe in individuals
should be able to get help in the way
that works for them and meets their
needs
together we can better support some of
the most vulnerable and marginalized
people in our district sharing the same
aims working collaboratively and working
with local people for the benefit of the
community
our trusted partnership already enables
us to understand respond and adapt to
local needs and we already share in
information initiate action however
there is a need to develop the
partnership and improve the joined up
working between the housing directorate
and citizens advice to make it strong
enough to support our residents moving
forward offering robust and resilient
solutions and services that will make
our communities stronger
i am pleased to see that the
recommendations from the joint overview
and scrutiny meeting on the 20th of
september and 20th december are
addressed by the council's response to
the cost of living crisis explained in
the previous report and the cost of
living action plan
i am particularly looking forward to
establishing a cost of living
coordinator which will continue to build
on the substantial operations we already
have in place including customer service
housing and welfare support and external
partnerships to ensure that partners are
talking to each other in meeting
people's needs the appointment of a
dedicated cost of living officer to
coordinate work systems and data will
strengthen already strong partnerships
arrangements and will support activity
that not only delivers much of the
activities set out in the cost of living
action plan but also satisfies the
recommendations made by overview and
scrutiny committee
in september and december 2021
the recommendations are detailed in this
report and i ask cabinet agree the
recommendations set out in
3.1
and just to add the post will
be across baylor and mid-southwark and
will be funded by a payment received by
the council for
dluhc which obviously is that
the uh leveling up um housing and
communities
thank you
and we will ask for a second to please
is councillor having a proposing in
council flatman seconding yes yeah okay
sorry to put words in your mouth
yes we're happy to do that chair
thank you
do we have any questions from members
counsellor
i've got quite a number of
uh questions having been
uh chair of being scrutiny um we're
referring here to two meetings of
overview of scrutiny um
so what i'd like to ask is what actions
have already been taken what agreements
have already been reached with
um citizens advice in respect of the
joint overview and scrutiny
recommendation of the 20th of september
2021 that urgent action is taken to
improve joined up working and creating
creation of a jointly funded post
i ask because local
communities advice
and joint overview security considered
this to be urgent eight months ago
um and it looks as if you're relying on
the cost of living co-ordinator so it
could well be
sort of 12 months it could we could be
round to august september by the time
that post
is filled
so
what steps have already been taken and
what improvements have been realized
we do have strong links with our
citizens of advice bureau and i know
nadine has been having meetings with
them
on a regular basis um we
you know we have taken all the all the
um comments from overview and scrutiny
and taken those forward
um
the answer to your question on um the
cost of living
coordinator this post you know will have
responsibility to ensure that our
partnership arrangements are
strengthened systems are in process and
aligned where possible improve the
sharing of information
to better target our support and to
ensure that resources follow priority is
to those most in need um yes we we are
in process of recent interview process
so as soon as that happens but we are
already working closely with our
partners
um the
suffolk public sector leaders have
underwritten one million pounds the cost
of living support which will support the
cas across suffolk with food and fuel
vouchers etc and mid-suffolk district
council has provided an uplift to the
mid-suffolk ca revenue grant for 22-23
um
you know so it is all in
it's all happening
and sorry can i just add to that i'm not
going to come up with the facts and
figures that um that julie has but i
just want to say that i feel that our
relationship with cb was is already
better than it was say a year ago and
with um when simon clifton first came on
i think you know he and vicki stu have
already got a good um relationship
together and i think it's already a lot
better than it has been previously
thank you thank you yeah i don't i'd
just like to bring the dean
in first thank you
i
i would absolutely echo um what both of
the councils have just stated i i would
also add
that we regularly meet with the cab we
have regular conversations in relation
to
information and intelligence that we've
shared and in terms of developing the
cost of living plan
cab has helped inform those
recommendations
as outlined by councillor richardson so
there is a
really good relationship between the
council and the cab what i'd also add
just from the point on urgency
um
it didn't require a scrutiny report to
emphasize that urgency that urgency has
already been we've already been having
conversations about those urgency issues
and been working on how we respond to
those issues so as council flatman has
said this is a ongoing
engagement and partnership with the ceb
and as council lavinia has just said
we have
enhanced that relationship with the cab
thank you chad yeah um yes i'm aware
that the partnership is working much
better one of the concerns from the
citizens advice was that they didn't
have direct uh
contact details in terms of telephone
numbers of
mid suffer housing staff
so prior to september 2021
and i hope this has now changed and you
can confirm whether or not it has
the only way that citizen's advice staff
could contact housing was through the
o300 number i trust that that now has
been sorted out thank you um
can i make it uh ask a question about
food banks um
there is a response in in in respect of
food banks in the
um
in the in the report and i'd ask for
further clarification from the cabinet
member if i may
the request from
the cas was that food banks supported by
mid suffolk or babru mid-suffolk
refer recipients of food a food to
citizens advice for advice you refer to
the the other way around in the report
but what was important from the point of
view of citizens advice was that rather
than the same people go back
time and time again to
food banks that it was almost a
requirement of the person receiving the
food to sort of break the cycle by
requiring them to go to cities as advice
for advice on nutrition finance benefits
and so on so has anything has there been
any progress on that please
sure um
so just just two things firstly
we we are aware that there was a report
that came from advice we relation to
food usage
and as i just stated in terms of
informing the
cost of living action plan
that intelligence that came from the
citizens advice bureau has informed
those recommendations that have come
forward
in addition to that particularly in
relation to the food economy
we've looked at this two ways one we've
i wanted to
understand some of the issues and the
needs that we need to address and that's
and that's why we have some of those
recommendations
but also what we're focusing on is how
do we actually break the cycle
and what we mean by that is
how do we support communities to help
themselves so one of the recommendations
in the cost of living plan is to
identify any green spaces where
communities actually grow their own
produce and in doing so
we're enabled to build resilient
communities support families and
actually have that much better
nutritional value
and just as a
also another precursor we're working
with the county
in relation to a piece of work that
they're undertaking with food banks
including working with the citizens
advice bureau
in terms of understanding some of those
causal issues so we know that there is
work underway and once that research has
been undertaken concluded we will then
respond to those recommendations
accordingly too
if i may please
and and that's around fun
just before you move off of food banks
um i'd also like to add that at suffolk
public sector leaders group last week
we approved over a million pounds to go
towards hardship funding as well
um
something like
um
where is it
60 plus food banks across suffolk
are already funded
and
this is via self-service and also from
eight hundred thousand pounds winter
grant scheme that sbsl funded
carry on with your next question yeah
thank you for that chad yeah i think
that the point that the
um citizens advice will make you
it's not as important to put money into
food banks as it is to make sure that
people come out of food poverty by
looking at other things like nutrition
um benefit
benefits finance and so on but thank you
for that
um
could you please um become a member and
confirm that lcas will be informed in
good time say by december 2022 of the
agreed uplift to the 20
20 23 24 grand um citizens advice are
concerned that
obviously mid-subway is one of their
major
sources of funding but
uh in in the past that that level of
funding hasn't been agreed until the
february that's just two months before
the start of their financial year
they really need to know a bit earlier
than that which was the reason why
overview and scrutiny
ask for the
inflation uplift to be
agreed year on year not just
you know each separate february thank
you
sorry
okay
yeah one of the recommendations from
overview and scrutiny was to index link
the ca revenue grant
but with the financial support in the
suffolk system at the moment and the
improvements to be developed by the cost
of living coordinator i don't think
index linking the revenue grant is the
most appropriate action to take it sets
expectation to other organizations in
receipt of revenue grants and presents
the need
but i do hope that we can just
inform ca yes you are going to get your
usual money and yes there may be um
each year but we can't say if we're
going to give them it won't be index
linked i can tell you that but we may be
looking at how much we give them each
year
and i know you said can they be informed
that they are going to get it well i'm
sure we can do that that they know
they're going to get their money as per
usual
thank you councillor flatman nadine did
you want to come back on that i did yes
thank you um chair um
two points firstly councilwollum will be
aware that we have given a 30 in europe
uplift to the citizen advice bureau
and even if we just for example focused
on
inflation and the index link that 30
actually surpasses that point the second
point that i would just make that is
this that
our staff regularly meet with the
citizens advice bureau so it's not just
as part of the budget cycle we have an
ongoing conversation
we want to understand that operating
models and issues demands that we need
to respond to
and in that context be able to respond
accordingly in terms of any
recommendations we put forward in any
budget setting process going forward
that helps with having a really mature
conversation with the citizens advice
bureau but it also enables us to
um start really thinking about how we
can
how the citrus advice bureau can
actually influence us but also how we
can actually influence that economy and
if i just give you that as an example
one of the things that it says in the
cost of living plan
that in terms of third sector commute
organizations because of covid were able
to digitize some of their operating
models that and created much more
resilience
in the system some of the kind of
initiatives that we're looking at this
moment in time is putting in place
pop-up clinics in those areas for
example where we're not able to deploy
resources we're only able to do that
because digitization has taken place
with those operating models
so what we are saying to the citizens
advice bureau is that if we're going to
ask you to deploy resources we need to
make sure that what we don't do is
destabilize some of your operations and
in that context how do we have a much
more mature conversation in relation to
the resources that you require so the
point i'm making council development is
that the conversation has really moved
on since the report that scrutiny um
discussed and the recommendations that
put forward
can i just say thank you for that um one
of the one of the difficulties is that
members generally don't know what's
going on um
i mean that's that's all really good
news or most of it's really good news um
and i know that uh you you were unhappy
with the suggestion that there should be
an observer at um
citizens advice trustees meetings but um
in the absence of an observer
could we have regular feedback of how
things are going at citizens advice at
this present time it is a really
important resource that we have out
there that's i mean it's like an extra
department of the district council and
we don't know what's going on it would
be useful if if we did have um more
information perhaps from the cabinet
member thank you
happy for that to occur
and if i could just add councillor
hattingham council flatman and i
regularly meet with
simon clifton
at the citizens
advice
and also all councillors get a
quarterly update direct from the cab
straight into their inboxes telling them
what's going on
anybody wish to debate this
okay
so the recommendations are that cabinet
considers the report from joint overview
and scrutiny and agrees their response
to the recommendations in the report as
detailed in
paragraph four
in line with the council's response to
the cost of living crisis
and
in line with the council's response to
the cost of living crisis and the
five-point plan that will look at a
better system of connectivity between
partners
including the local citizens advice the
council and system-wide partners
and i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
thank you members the vote is now in
progress
chairman that should take your vote
please
chair that is eight votes for that's
unanimous
excellent
thank you moving on to item 11
is mca
22-5
the stone market health education
leisure facilities
known as shelf
and
i'm going to invite the cabinet member
for
for health and wellbeing to introduce
the report thank you
thank you very much chair
i'm delighted to introduce the initial
business case for the stone market
health education and leisure facility
and to outline the next steps that if
approved we will take to further develop
this proposal
this facility better known as the shelf
project represents a significant program
of work that would considerably enhance
the sport and leisure provision within
mid suffolk facilitate the much needed
expansion of stone market high school
and develop a new innovative well-being
hub to enable the co-location of
services with our partners in health and
social care
particular highlights in the sport
provision include a 4g football pitch a
mini track athletics facility four new
indoor sport courts a new small pavilion
a new cricket square and a multi-surface
perimeter track
i am perhaps perhaps unsurprisingly
especially excited about the prospect of
a well-being hub in the heart of
mid-suffolk for those colleagues who
were able to attend the site visits to
colchester and mildenhall we were able
to see just how effective these
facilities can be and how popular they
are with both service providers and
service users
this project will also represent a major
realization of our well-being strategy
and the updated leisure sport and
physical activity strategy both of which
were published last year
there is a broader point here as well
that i would like to stress that despite
the pressures and challenges of the
kovic 19 pandemic both on finance and
personnel mid-suffolk is still in a
position to be potentially making a
major investment in our communities
on a practical level this paper is
asking cabinet to endorse the initial
business case and the cost of seven
hundred thousand pounds is outlined in
paragraph 6.4 to take this project to
its next stage
if approved by cabinet this will then be
considered by full council at the end of
the month and the intention would then
be to develop these proposals further
including finalized detail and cost on
cost and funding with the
with a full business case submitted to
cabinet and full council again aiming by
the end of this year
finally i'd like to add my thanks to
council brewster who unfortunately can't
be here and the economy team
for leading on his work and engaging so
proactively with such a large number of
stakeholders right across
our community and indeed with other
national sporting bodies
in short i think this is a really
exciting and ambitious opportunity for
mid-suffolk and so i'm very happy to
propose the recommendations uh in the
paper and i would look for a second
thank you chair
thank you councillor flatman
i've got to second it haven't i i mean
what a fantastic project with um a
school with a mental health um hub there
for
teenagers to use as well the sports
facilities are going to be absolutely
wonderful and thank you to fiona and her
team for organizing the trip for us to
go to colchester milgan hall and look
around where everything's going to go at
stone market is absolutely brilliant and
if we can get anything near what milder
normal had but i expect ours will be
better don't you yeah absolutely thanks
a lot
thank you
so this report contains confidential
appendices so if members wish to
question
and debate those appendices then the
meeting will go into closed session
and then come back to public session for
the debate
and the the vote will be taken in open
session
so do we have any questions from members
councillor
what i really like to do is thank fiona
and others for
the opportunities that a number of us
have had to look at the details and make
comment um so if i've got to ask a
question it will have to be um can we
please continue to look at the
accessibility for on foot on cycle and
the the potential for
um car sharing and so on because this
is going to be a lot of traffic
generated by by this project and we need
to make sure that we
get people there safely across the road
safely
and from one area to the other and
without using too many four by fours and
large vehicles to get there thank you
i don't think he needs an answer but i
had to put it in the form of a question
you don't mean it's not actually a
question
would you mind telling me michael thank
you councillor richardson uh thank you
chair i'll just say yes
cancer field
thank you i think this is a question um
obviously an excellent thing to be doing
i'm always aware that
when
blaken fields was developed there was
money put aside for sports development
at clayton high
which obviously is not that far from
stone market but is a different
community
so there's sort of two hundred thousand
pounds there and another two hundred
thousand pounds
for brantford picnic cycle
could be divided i just wonder whether
there's any possibility that you you
will be encouraging um perhaps something
obviously not as grand but something
similar
in what is uh
actually councillor whitehead's area
nowadays
it would be good not to see all that
cash disappear back into it
i say a builder's pocket
thank you chair and thank you for the
question cansterfield um i'll be careful
what i do say on the question of some of
the funding because that will stray into
the um
confidentially exempt items in terms of
i think one point about sort of a broad
reflection on this particular project is
that it's been
um or the prospect of this project i
should say is very much contingent on a
number of different converging factors
so the fact that it is co-located next
to our leisure center the fact that so
stow market high is already relatively
um
it's been acknowledged that it needs to
expand the fact that there's a large
amount of land available the fact that
there's a development site attracting
sill um next to it i think is is are all
sort of major contributing factors to
how we can we can take this forward but
obviously it's not to say that we um
wouldn't be looking at other potential
improvements across the district um as a
as an entirely separate um to this
project what i think it is worth
reflecting on the reason why we've at
the moment taken this forward um and
what we tend to be guided by is a lot of
the provision that's outlined in
um this in the actual site plan itself
has been based on the needs assessment
that was completed as part of the
leisure sport physical activity strategy
last year um so that identified
particular shortfalls where mid suffolk
didn't have the same facilities that
other better equipped
areas in the country did have and so
that's what's informed um the planning
around this particular project but
certainly
we know that this won't satisfy all of
our needs so there'll be other
opportunities that will come that will
arise in the future
i do think it a bit unfair to ask
councillor richardson a question that
it's not in the paper
but uh
thank you for your reply and away
council richardson
so um
given that we have
no uh confidential questions or sort of
questions on the confidential papers
council richardson
not richardson pointed it sorry
yeah i have some real concerns about the
finance and basically on the first
sentence of the first part of the
question would
delve into the
um confidential
area i think
so uh to go into closed session um
we need to consider whether pursuant to
part one of schedule 12a of the local
government act 1972
the public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds but if the public were
present during this item it is likely
that there would be the disclosure to
them of exempt information as indicated
against the item
the author of the report proposed to be
considered in part two of the agenda
is satisfied that the public interest in
maintaining the exemption outweighs the
public interest in disclosing the
information
so it could have a proposer and seconder
to go into
private privatization council richardson
councillor whitehead thank you
can you conduct the vote please thank
you thank you chair the vote is in
progress on your app
thank you
counselor gould
thank you
we're now into
debate
um who wants to
debate this item
no okay so the recommendations
are
the cabinet considers and approves the
master plan at appendix a
and the initial business case at
appendix b
which is restricted
for the proposed scheme which includes
an indicative cost plan and funding
strategy
the cabinet notes the work to date on
the partnership strategy appendix a
which is restricted
and future management models appendix d
also restricted for the new hub as
detailed
the cabinet endorses the recommendations
to council for further funding to
complete the scheme to detailed design
stage and submission of a planning
application
next management modelling and a two-year
partnership coordinator to fully
maximize current and future partnership
working and collaboration across the
site outlined in section 6.4
and i'm going to now ask the
government's officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
chair mayor take your vote please
thank you
thank you uh that is eight votes for and
that's unanimous chair
thank you very much
so that concludes today's
business cabinet business the date and
time of the next meeting is scheduled
for monday the 4th of july
and will start at 10 30.
thank you
you